tu te situes pour les téléspectateurs
français un petit peu ton ge je suis une
chanteur romantique je
chante
d'amour
C
cour on va t'écouter dans une chanson
ravissante chanson d'amour évidemment
italienne qui s'appelle er non c'était
ou c'était pas
[Applaudissements]
indnyz
[Musique]
son giunto fino a
quiato
mi
[Musique]
resp volava la
giornata l'amore che cosè se non
[Musique]
un'emozione liber la mente e al Cu da
ragione era o non era un affare di cuore
soltanto il profumo di
quell'atmosfera
era o non era ti vedevo più bella più
Dolce che mai mi sembravi più
vera è giusto pure
no a un
[Musique]
senentqueanto l'amore che cos'è se non
guardarsi
dentro e Fars
trasportare comee fogli al
ventoa o non era un affare di cuore o
soltanto il profumo di
quell'atmosfera era o non era ti vedevo
più bella più Dolce che mai mi Semra
[Musique]
eraera